what's up everyone its Warren and the
Internet has been a freaking out over
the past couple of days rightfully so
because Marvel has announced five new
slots for Phase five Disney put five new
days on their calendar and everybody is
trying to figure out what these movies
could be but luckily for us we've pretty
much narrowed down what these new five
movies are going to be in phase five
narrow down all of the logic that says
that these are going to be the movies
and the evidence that we have so far
things that have come from previous
movies and things that people have said
at Marvel Studios such as Kevin Feige at
the President himself so let's break
down what we expect these movies to be
and how it's most likely that the x-men
and/or the Fantastic Four are going to
be making their MCU debut in phase 5
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
with the notifications turned on and
leave a like on the video so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 you can also click the
link in the description below for your
chance to win an Infinity Gauntlet so in
case you missed it before as I mentioned
in the beginning of the video Marvel has
officially released five new dates for
Phase five and these new dates are
October 7th of 2022 February 17th of
2023 May 5th of 2023 July 28th of 2023
and November 3rd of 2023 and this
doesn't come as too much of a surprise
because Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios has already stated on the
record that they have phase 5 done they
know what it's going to be and they
almost announced it at San Diego
comic-con and Disney's d23 event but
decided not to and for good reason
because if all of these phase 5 movies
end up being what we expect them to be
and end up being what all of the
evidence points towards them being then
phase 4 is going to get blown away by
phase 5 don't get me wrong phase 4 is
going to be super exciting but let's
take a look at what phase 5 movies are
most likely going to be coming to the
MCU so to start off we already have many
movies that are literally confirmed to
by Marvel themselves to be coming in the
future of the MCU black panther 2 has
already been confirmed for phase 5 but
it is not going to take one of these
slots as it has already been confirmed
that it is going to be released on may
6th of 2022 but the other films that
have been confirmed that are going to be
in the future of the MCU are Captain
Marvel - guardians of the galaxy vol 3
Ant Man 3 bleh
the Fantastic Four and the x-men now
just because these movies are confirmed
to be coming to the MCU does not mean
that they are necessarily going to come
in phase five however we do know how
Marvel operates they plan everything way
in advance and usually they don't
mention or comment on things unless
there's already something in the works
for these films but there are still some
films that haven't been officially
confirmed by Marvel that are most likely
going to come sooner than later such as
Deadpool 3 but the industry insiders and
experts have all come up with lists of
what they expect phase 5 to be and
they're all pretty much the same and as
I mentioned there's a lot of backing
behind this list so let's go through
number one coming in at the first phase
5 slot of February 18th 2022 is Deadpool
3
now even though Marvel has not
officially revealed that Deadpool 3 is
coming this one makes a lot of sense and
Kevin Feige has confirmed that Deadpool
is now being run by Marvel Studios after
the Disney Fox deal has come to a
completion and although it is not a
direct confirmation Ryan Reynolds did
post on his Instagram many different
things about Deadpool coming to phase 5
including very recently a picture of him
at Marvel Studios but there's a
particular reason of why Deadpool 3
works for the first phase 5 slot
february 18th of 2022 really is not that
far away and Deadpool 3 doesn't really
require that much work at least not
nearly as much as all of the new
properties that are going to be coming
to phase 5 the Deadpool franchise is
basically already set up Ryan Reynolds
is Deadpool and it's really the perfect
way to start bringing in those Fox
characters that Disney has because
you're not going to start off with the
x-men or the Fantastic Four or doom or
the Silver Surfer Galactus but you can
start off with a character that is
already developed has his own franchise
and has the ability to break the fourth
wall and his ability to break the fourth
wall would be a really great way to
introduce the new properties into the
new universe so that could very well be
the first movie we see in phase 5 and
the second in the may 6th of 2022 spot
we already know is going to be black
panther 2 so that's already confirmed
but coming in at the July 29th of 2022
spot is ant-man
3
and there's a few different reasons of
why this release date makes perfect
sense for ant-man three one is that we
have just heard that ant-man 3 is going
to begin filming in 2021
that means a release date of July 2022
would give the studio plenty of time to
film edit and promote the movie not to
mention it seems to be a pretty good
spot for a sequel just like the slot
before it is black panther 2 but it's a
sequel that is going to have a lot of
importance to it the biggest thing most
likely going to be that it's going to
set up the Young Avengers now will most
likely have already seen some Young
Avengers by the time this comes out
Wanda and vision is going to introduce
Wiccan and speed and of course the
Hawkeye series is going to introduce
Kate Bishop but an Avengers in game
Cassy Lang definitely looked like she
was ready to be a young Avenger for
those of you who do not know Cassy Lang
in the comics does go on to become
stature and yes she is in the Young
Avengers and not to mention that both
ant-man and ant-man and the loss pad
July release dates as well so this makes
perfect sense coming in at the October
7th of 2022 spot is blade now this would
really be a perfect time to introduce
this movie because of Halloween it's a
vampire movie it has sort of a scary
vibe to it it's a perfect opportunity
for that October 7th release date and
not to mention that this is a phase 5
movie that was actually announced at San
Diego Comic Con during the reveal of
phase 4 so development on the movie has
definitely already began and in October
of 2022 a late 2022 spot would give them
enough time to fully develop and
complete the movie and the fact that
they announced it at San Diego Comic Con
during the reveal of phase 4 means that
it is coming sooner than later the next
one is a big one coming in on the
february 17th spot of 2023 is the
Fantastic Four now it seems very likely
that ant-man 3 is going to set up the
debut of the Fantastic Four in phase 5
the director has already pointed out the
quantum city in the quantum realm and
said that it is going to be of big
importance in the future of the MCU and
it's widely believed that that is where
the Fantastic Four currently are so
ant-man 3 could set up the Fantastic
Four to make their debut and they MCU
only a couple of movies later and again
this is a movie that
has been confirmed by Kevin Feige at San
Diego comic-con and he did mention that
we would see the Fantastic Four arrive
in the MCU before we would see the x-men
make their appearance there definitely
not a rush for Marvel to get out but a
2023 spot gives them plenty of time to
fully develop the movie and not to
mention it offers a perfect opportunity
to introduce a major villain Doctor Doom
Marvel is going to want to build up a
villain over time just like they did
Thanos but they need somebody who can
outdo Thanos well the Fantastic Four is
setting up god-emperor doom in the
future would definitely do the trick
coming in on the may 5th of 2023 spot is
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 this is
kind of a no-brainer considering the
fact that guardians of the galaxy 3 has
been confirmed by Marvel for a very long
time now however at the director and
writer James Gunn is tied up with the
Suicide Squad right now
so unfortunately he cannot begin to work
on guardians of the galaxy 3 until he is
done with the Suicide Squad and the
Suicide Squad 2 doesn't come out until
mid 2021 so that's when James Gunn would
officially begin to work on guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 and a may 2023 spot
would give him plenty of time to get the
movie done coming in at the July 28th of
2023 slot is Captain Marvel - Captain
Marvel - has been confirmed for a pretty
long time now especially given the
success that the first Captain Marvel
had however there has been no talk about
any development on the movie happening
anytime soon but of course we know that
the movie is indeed going to happen and
it has been reported that Captain Marvel
2 could be somewhat of a crossover event
nothing has been confirmed by Captain
Marvel - could most likely set up the
Secret Invasion storyline this would
most likely kick off a pretty big story
in the MCU coming to phase 6
not to mention Captain Marvel - code
introduced the sword organization based
off of the post-credits scene for
Captain Marvel it seems like Nick Fury
was at the sword headquarters and based
off of the fact that we have learned
that Nick Fury has actually been a
Skrull since the events of Captain
America the Winter Soldier it seems like
a Secret Invasion story is definitely
upon us and then coming in at the
November third of 2023 spot is Nova now
this spot is kind of interchangeable
with the x-men but I'll talk more about
that
just a bit Nova has not been officially
confirmed however Kevin Feige has
mentioned it many many times back in
2017 Kevin Feige said that Nova has
immediate potential in the MCU and since
then he has commented a few times
stating that that is still the same
we know that Nova was originally
supposed to be introduced in guardians
of the galaxy volume 1 and then he was
supposed to be in Avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame as well obviously
they ultimately ended up not putting him
in Avengers infinity war or endgame but
they tried which means they are trying
to get him in the MCU somehow and after
Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame there's a pretty big hole in the
MCU and that hole is Xander we know that
Xander was extremely important to the
guardians of the galaxy and we know that
Thanos decimated it and according to
what was supposed to be the story for
Nova and Avengers infinity war
Richard Reiter was going to be the only
survivor of zan Dart
therefore he would inherit the entire
Nova force becoming Nova so it seems
like this has already happened in the
MCU we just haven't seen it yet so
seeing Nova and his story of what
happened is long overdue but then again
if Marvel really wanted to they could
introduce the x-men however they are
most likely going to be patient when it
comes to introducing the x-men into the
MCU especially because we just got x-men
dark Phoenix and there's no doubt that
Marvel is definitely going to want to
separate the two universes the Fox x-men
and the MCU x-men as much as they can so
therefore allowing more time between the
two of them is better for them not to
mention there is a lot of pressure on
the MCU x-men so Marvel is going to have
to take their time and determinate the
perfect actors and actresses for these
roles
not to mention they'll have to get the
perfect story as well so unfortunately
they'll most likely reserve the x-men
for Phase six or a major crossover event
but right now as it stands this list is
pretty widely accepted from everybody in
the Marvel world and if this does indeed
end up becoming the phase 5 list are you
happy with this let me know if you are
and let me know what you would change in
the comments down below also don't
forget to subscribe with the
notifications turned on and like the
video to enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 also click
the link in the description down below
to enter for your chance to win
and Infinity Gauntlet and don't forget
to use code cosmic when you buy G fuel
at G fuel calm as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof